learn how to build a platformer game in
Python this game will have collisions
gravity animated characters and much
much more Tim with tech with Tim teaches
this course Tim is one of the most
subscribed software channels on YouTube
[Music]
[Applause]
in this video I'll be sharing with you
how to build a platformer game in Python
this game will have Pixel Perfect
Collision it will have an animated
character as you can see here it will
have single and double jumping it will
have all kinds of different animations
for falling jumping colliding with
obstacles for example you can see here
when I hit the fire I kind of go into
this hit State I will show you how to
generate different objects how to scroll
the background and really at the end of
this video you will have a solid
fundamental understanding of how to
build a platformer game in Python and
you can go and extend this and build
really anything that you can think of
I'll leave include a ton of free assets
for you that allow you to change your
character change the terrain change the
background and do all of that extremely
easily in fact in this tutorial alone I
will show you how to use four different
characters let me show you those
characters before we continue so this is
the second character here this is being
referred to as mask dude this is the
third character I'm calling this guy the
ninja Frog as you can see and finally we
have this character here which is called
pink man now in this tutorial you will
learn how to use all of these characters
and you can swap them out with a single
line of code alright so let's go ahead
and get into it now since this is a long
video I do want to spend a minute here
just talking about who this video is
designed for exactly what you're going
to learn and what you can expect just so
you don't waste your time if you don't
want to go through it so this video is
really designed for people that have a
bit of experience with python ideally
you are an intermediate python
programmer you understand the syntax you
know for Loops you know functions you
know all of that if you don't feel free
to follow along but I'm not going to be
explaining those basic concepts now this
video will teach you how to build
exactly what you see here so by the end
of the video you will have exactly this
and if you're not interested in waiting
until the end of the video then you can
download the code from the GitHub
repository that I will leave in the
description that's also where all the
assets are going to be so regardless
you're going to have to download the
code from GitHub again I will leave that
in the description download that open up
the folder and kind of we can start
working from there now really what I'm
going to be showing you here mostly is
Sprite sheet animation uh Pixel Perfect
Collision using what's called masks and
then how you can do the scrolling
background generating objects all of
that kind of stuff that is really the
hard part when it comes to generating a
platform or game once you have all of
that down it's very easy to extend this
to add levels to add like you know a
finishing flag to add coins to add you
know lives you can turn this game into
anything you want and that's how I've
designed this so that you have the base
and then you can go and make it kind of
a full-fledged game and work off of that
so with that said I will stop talking
now I think this game looks really good
I'm excited to share this with you guys
so let's get into actually building it
so right now I have Visual Studio code
open obviously we're doing this in
Python and I already have Pi game
installed now the first thing we're
going to have to do is install pygame
which is the module we're going to be
using so to do that go to your terminal
and type pip install Pi game if that
doesn't work for you you're going to try
pip 3 install Pi game if that doesn't
work try python
hyphen M hip install Pi game if that
doesn't work try Python 3 hyphen ampip
install Pi game if none of those work I
will leave two videos on the screen that
show you how to install that module now
once you have Pi game installed I'm
going to assume that you've downloaded
the GitHub repository go to GitHub
there's a little button that says click
to download download the folder extract
it to your desktop and then open it in
vs code or whatever editor you want so
you have something that looks like this
you should have an assets directory
inside of assets you should have a bunch
of different folders then you should
have a main python file that contains
all of the finished code now obviously
we're going to write the code from
scratch but you can either work off that
existing code or you can kind of clear
the file and type along with me whatever
you want to do I quickly want to run you
through the assets folder and then we'll
get into the code so in assets we have a
ton of stuff we're not going to use most
of this but I wanted to include all of
it so that you could kind of continue
the game later if you want so we have
for example backgrounds these are a
bunch of background tiles so you can
change kind of the theme or color the
background very easily I'll show you how
to do that we have items like boxes
checkpoints fruits Etc we're not going
to use any of those then we have main
characters for main characters we have a
bunch of sprite sheets inside of here
and I'll show you how we can split these
Sprite sheets apart and use all of the
different kind of animations inside of
here right
so we have that for Mass dude ninja frog
Pinkman and virtual guy all of the file
names are the exact same okay then we
have menu we're not going to be using
anything from there we have other we
have terrain we are actually going to be
using terrain specifically we're going
to pull out this kind of block here but
you could change the block again if you
want to do that and then we have traps
and we are going to be using the fire
trap wherever that is right here that
has kind of an animation right where the
fire is going but again you can add all
of this stuff later on I'll show you
kind of the base on how to do it and
then you'll be able to extend from there
okay now that we understand the assets I
apologize for such a long introduction
let's get into writing the code I also
need to plug the idea of the course
programmingexpert.io if you guys want to
get better at python check that out from
the link in the description
okay so let's start at the top of our
program here by importing everything we
need we're going to import OS we're
going to import random we're going to
import math we're going to import pygame
we're going to say from OS import list
directory
and we're going to say from os.path
import is file and join now the reason
I'm doing all this OS stuff is because
we are going to be dynamically loading
all of the Sprite sheets and the images
so we don't have to manually like type
out the file names that we want I'll
show you how we write a function that
just loads these folders here kind of
splits the Sprite sheets automatically
and gives us all the images that we're
interested in okay after we do that
we're going to say pygame.net we need to
initialize the pi gate module then we're
going to go down here we're going to set
a caption for a display I'm going to say
Pi game dot display dot set underscore
caption if you're unfamiliar with what
this is doing this is setting the
caption at the top of the window I'll
try to explain most the pi game stuff as
we go through the video I also have a
ton of videos on Pi game on my channel
if you want to check out something a
little bit more basic okay now what I'm
going to do is Define a few Global
variables that we're going to be using
here the first one is going to be the
background color now we'll use this for
now until we Implement our own
background and for the background color
I'm going to make this white which is
going to be 255 255 255 all of our
colors in pi game are going to be an RGB
okay so red green blue that's what we
have for our background color we're then
going to define the width and the height
of our screen
for some of you you're gonna have to
make this smaller if you're on a smaller
display for me I'm on a 2K monitor so
I'm going to go with a thousand by 800
but if you're on again a smaller screen
you might want to make this just a bit
smaller so that it works for you
although it doesn't really matter
um make it whatever size you want next
I'm going to say my FPS which is my
frames per second is going to be equal
to 60 and I'm going to Define my player
velocity equal to 5 and this is going to
be the speed at which my player moves
around the screen
okay now that we've done that we need to
set up a pi game window
so I'm going to say
pygame.display.set underscore mode and
then I'm going to pass the width and the
height to this window argument here this
mode argument and this is going to kind
of create the pi game window for us
I'm going to store that in the window
variable and there we go we have kind of
our Global variables created
now I'm going to make a main function
I'm going to say to find Main
this main function is going to be what
we run to kind of start the game
so inside of here I'm going to take a
window and at the bottom of my program
I'm going to say if underscore
underscore name underscore underscore is
equal to underscore underscore Main
underscore underscore then
call the main function and pass the
window argument
okay so hopefully you can see kind of
the structure of our program already the
reason I have this line right here is so
that we only call the main function if
we run this file directly if we don't
run this file directly say we imported
something from it then we won't run the
game code okay
so that's why I have this inside of main
is where we're going to write kind of
our event Loop the event Loop will be
what's handling say the Collision moving
our character redrawing the window all
of that kind of stuff this kind of good
practice to have your event Loop in one
place
so inside of the main function we need
to set up a few things the first thing
we need is a clock so we're going to say
clock is equal to pygame dot time dot
clock we also need to Define uh what is
it a while loop that's going to
continually Loop and act as our event
Loop so I'm going to say run is equal to
true
I'm going to say while true or well run
sorry and then the first thing I'm going
to do is say clock.tick FPS now FPS
members our variable right here what
this line does is ensures that our while
loop is gonna run
um 60 frames per second okay so no more
than 60 times per second that's what
this ensures if you're on a really slow
computer chances are you could be
running less than 60 frames per second
but in my case I'm on quite a fast
computer and if I didn't put this here
then you'd see that my game would be
like way faster than yours so we need to
do this to regulate the frame rate
across different devices okay now that
we have that we're going to say four
event in pygame dot event dot get and
the first event that we're going to
check for is if the user quits the game
if they quit by quitting I mean they hit
the red X in the top right hand corner
then we need to stop the event Loop and
exit our program so I'm going to say if
event DOT type
is equal to pygame dot quit then we're
going to say run
is equal to false and we can break out
of this Loop
then we can go down here and we can say
higame dot quit notice this is outside
of the while loop
and then we can put quit which will
actually quit the Python program okay
so now we have our basic event Loop and
what should happen if I run the code now
is a pi game window should pop up
nothing should be on the screen and if I
hit the red arrow it should close so
let's try this and see what we get okay
notice it says platformer and then I hit
X and it closes perfect uh we're well on
our way to creating the platformer game
all right so now that we've done that I
actually think that the first thing we
can do is generate our background then
once we have the background we can
create a basic player that we can move
around the screen and once we have that
we'll start doing all of the animations
and then later in the video once we've
got uh kind of the bulk of the stuff
done we'll handle it the collision and
all of the movements right
okay so I need to make a function here
and I'm going to call this get
underscore background
now before I dive into this let's have a
look at our assets folder again
now what I want to do is use these tiles
right they're just tiles I believe their
size is 64 by 64 or 32 by 32 something
along those lines anyways we'll want to
use these tiles and tile the whole
background
so what I need to do is essentially
create a whole grid of these tiles based
on the size of my screen so the way I'm
going to do that is by using a folder
here this folder is going to return to
me sorry not this folder my bad this
function this function is going to
return to me a list that contains all of
the background tiles that we need to
draw so that's what we're going to do
here with get background now what we
want to take is the name
sorry as I was saying the name is going
to be the color of our background and
that's going to allow us to change what
background that we're using so the first
thing we need to do here is load this
background image now it's very important
that when you run this file you run it
from the directory that the file exists
in now the reason I'm saying that right
now is because the way I'm going to load
this image relies on the fact that
you're running this code from the
directory that it exists in so see here
that I'm in desktop python platformer
and then notice tutorials inside of that
directory that's why this is going to
work if you try to run this code from a
different directory say a CD to desktop
and then I tried to run this then I'm
going to get an issue so just make sure
you're in the correct directory I just
want to say that before we even get into
this okay so I'm going to load my image
I'm going to say image is equal to
pygame dot image dot load
and then what I'm going to do is join
the assets path which is directly in the
directory this file is in with the
background uh path here if I spell
background correctly and then with the
name which is going to be the file name
that I want to load which is really just
the color of the background okay now
that I have that I want to get the width
and the height of this image so I'm not
guessing what it is so I'm going to say
underscore underscore with height is
equal
to image.get underscore rect now when
you do this it will give you the X Y
width height I don't care about the X Y
so I've just put two underscores here
denoting that I don't care about these
values and then I'm able to grab the
width and the height so now that I have
the width and the height
I'm going to say tiles is equal to an
empty list and then I'm going to Loop
through
um essentially how many tiles I need to
create in the X and the Y Direction
so I'm going to say 4i in range and I'm
going to take my width I'm going to
integer divide this by the width of my
tile and I'm going to add one and I'm
going to do the same thing for my height
here so I'm going to say 4J in range
height over the height of my image Plus
1.
okay so notice width here is the width
of the screen height is the height of
the screen I'm integer dividing this by
the width of my tile and that tells me
approximately how many tiles I need kind
of in The X direction to fill the whole
screen
then just to make sure that I don't have
any gaps I add one and I do the exact
same thing for height in the y direction
then what I'm going to do is say
actually
yeah I'm going to say rect uh is this
wrecked no we're going to say pause is
equal to I multiply by the width and J
multiplied by the height and this is
going to denote the position of the top
left hand corner of the current tile
that I'm adding to this tiles list in pi
game when you draw something on the
screen you draw it from the top left
hand corner so what I'll be doing is
continually moving the positions based
on how this for Loop is going right so
for every eye for every J I'm
multiplying it by the width and
multiplying it by the height and that
gives me the accurate positions I need
to place every single tile in on the
screen
hopefully that makes a bit of sense but
that's how this is working and then I'm
going to say towels.append my position
and then I'm going to return my tiles
I'm also going to return the image so
that I can know what image I need to use
when I'm drawing all of these tiles okay
now that I have my background I'm going
to go into Main and I'm going to say my
background is equal to get background
and for the name I'm going to reference
here in the background folder any of
these images so we can use anyone we
want it doesn't really matter I kind of
like the blue one so I'll go with blue
feel free to change this though on your
end and
there we go if I can type this correctly
okay so I'm going to say background
comma
BG image like that
and now I want to set up something
that's going to draw my background so
I'm going to make a function here and
I'm going to say draw this is going to
take in a window and for now it's going
to take in a background and later it'll
take in everything else we want to draw
inside of here I'm going to say Pi game
dot display dot update
and before I do that I'm going to draw
my background so I'm going to say
4 and this is going to be tile in
backgrounds like that and then I'm going
to say window
dot blit and actually I need to take my
BG image as well
so let's take that
and I'm going to draw the background
image
and then what I need to pass here is the
position I want to draw it at which is
going to be tile so what I can actually
do is just convert this to a tuple
notice the tile is going to be a list
right tile is going to contain kind of
my X Y position you can see that here
right we're appending pause which is a
list of x y and now that I think of it
to make it easier let's just make this a
tuple directly and now we don't need to
convert it
okay so in case anyone's confused what
we're doing here is looping through
every single tile that we have and then
we're going to draw our background image
at that position which will fill the
entire screen with background images
then what we're going to do is update
the display the reason we update it so
that every single frame we kind of clear
the screen right and we don't have old
drawings still on the screen you'll see
what I mean in a second but this draw
function is what we're going to do all
of our drawing for now the only thing we
need to draw is the background later it
will be the player the blocks the
obstacles Etc
okay so now I'm going to go inside of my
while loop I'm going to call this draw
function that we just created I'm going
to pass window and then of course I'm
going to pass my background and my BG
image okay now this reminds me that I no
longer need this background color we're
not going to use that so I can get rid
of that there
okay so at this point assuming I've
loaded the image correctly we're now
going to see this tiling the entire
screen so let's save and run and notice
that we get it right it's tiling the
entire screen looks pretty good to me
and we can quite easily change this if
we want by just going here and saying
okay rather than blue I want yellow and
then we say yellow and now we get a
yellow background great so that's kind
of the advantage of how I've done this
here you can change the background to
any color you want well given that it's
in the background directory
now that we have our background what
should we do next well we probably want
to put a player on the screen and start
seeing some images for that player now
the player itself is the most
complicated aspect of this program
there's a lot of movement going on with
it so we'll start by just creating like
a block for our player kind of move the
block around have it jumping around then
once we do that we'll do all of the
Sprites and animations just so that we
can get some more progress before we
dive into that because it is a bit of
work okay so let's go here and let's say
class player
we're going to use a class for our
player it kind of makes sense here and
this class is going to inherit from
pygame dot Sprite dot Sprite now I don't
typically use Sprites when I'm working
in pi game but I'm going to use them in
this tutorial and the reason for that is
that it makes it very easy to do Pixel
Perfect Collision when we have two
Sprite objects which we're going to have
because we're inheriting from the pi
game Sprite class we can use a method
that tells us if these Sprites are
colliding with each other so just
understand that's why I'm doing this
inheritance you don't have to understand
exactly what the Sprite is but it kind
of denotes that we have some properties
on our class and then it allows these
special Pi game methods to use those
properties to handle the Collision for
us so we don't have to write anything
too complicated when it comes to the
Collision although we still do need to
handle it a bit okay so what we're going
to do here is Define our initialization
and we're going to take in a self an X Y
width and height
now the width and height will really be
determined by the image that we're using
for our player but for now since we're
going to have like a block for our
player until we add that image we're
going to have a width and height now
that reminds me that I just need to set
a color for my player so I'm going to
say color it's 255.00 I'm making this a
class variable just so it's the same for
all of my players and I have access to
it just right on the class
okay now what I'm going to do is say
self.rect is equal to pygame dot rect
I'm going to pass my X Y width and
height
so rather than representing all of these
values individually we're just going to
put them on the rectangle and this is
going to make it a little bit easier for
us to kind of move the play around and
do collision and all of that so erect
really is just a tuple that's storing
four individual values when I make it Pi
game.rect it means we can use it in some
kind of special equations and whatnot
okay now for our player we're gonna have
to have a few values uh the first thing
we're going to have I'm getting a bit
ahead of myself here but is going to be
the x velocity and the next is going to
be the Y velocity now the X and Y
velocity is going to denote
um what do you call it here how fast we
are moving our player every single frame
in both directions right so the way that
we'll actually move our player is we'll
just apply a velocity in a direction and
then it'll just keep moving in that
direction until we remove that velocity
now this will be great for example for
something like gravity or jumping
um and you'll you'll see what I mean in
a minute
okay now that we have that we need to
add something known as a mask for now
I'm going to say the mask is equal to
none and then I think that's all we need
for right now so now that we have that
let's add our first function here which
is going to be the move function so move
is going to take in a displacement in
the X Direction and a displacement in
the y direction and it's going to say
the self.rec dot X plus equals the
Direction X or displacement X sorry and
self.rect.y
plus equals the displacement y now if we
want to move upward down or left or
right we just change the sign of this DX
or d y right
okay
so now we have a move next what we want
to do is create two functions one for
moving to the left
and this is going to take in the
velocity we want to move in the left
Direction and the next is going to be
moving in the right direction again this
is going to take in self and Vel now to
move left what we're going to do is say
our self dot x velocity is equal to and
then this is going to be negative
velocity and then to move to the right
we're going to say self.xfel is equal to
Vel now the reason we use negative
velocity here is because if we want to
go left we have to subtract from our X
position in pi game remember our
coordinate system is that 0 0 is the top
left hand corner of the screen so if I
want to move down I add to my
y-coordinate and if I want to move to
the right I add to my x coordinate so if
I want to go up I subtract y if I want
to go left I subtract X so that's why
I'm putting a negative Val here I know
it seems a bit weird how I've just done
move and now I'm saying move left we're
going to have negative don't worry
you'll see how this works in a second
next I'm going to say if self dot Direct
action does not equal left
then self Dot
Direction
is equal to left and I'm going to say
self.animation count is equal to zero
now we're not going to use these right
now but I just want to add them in
um
for now at least and you'll see why in a
second now I'm also going to say appear
yourself.direction is equal to left and
the reason I'm adding this direction is
because I need to keep track of what
direction my player is facing so later
once I have my Sprites I know if I'm
showing the animation to the left or I'm
showing the animation to the right now
the animation count uh we're resetting
that when we change directions and the
reason we're doing that is so that the
animation doesn't look all wonky when we
go from going left to right so we need
to kind of reset the count that we're
using to change the animation frames
again you're going to see that later as
we go through the tutorial now I've just
added up here um self the animation
count equals zero just to make sure we
don't get any weird errors later so now
I have my direction and my animation can
perfect
okay now I'm going to copy this I'm
going to put the same thing in move
right and I'm going to change the
direction here to say right
and then right so now we know what
direction we're facing at all points in
time
okay
perfect next what we need to do is we
need to have some kind of draw function
and we also need to have what I'm going
to call the loop function and in fact
let's do the loop function first so I'm
going to say Define Loop
and inside of here I'm going to take in
self and FPS now what Loop is going to
do is be called once every frame when I
say frame that's really one iteration of
the while loop and this is going to move
our character in the correct direction
and handle things like updating the
animation and
all of the stuff that we constantly need
to do for our character so for right now
I only care about moving in the X
Direction we'll handle the jumping later
so what I'm going to do is just say self
dot move
and I'm going to say
that we're going to move based on our x
velocity
and our y velocity
now notice we're updating our x velocity
here when we move left or we move to the
right so now if we call Loop and we have
some velocity in the X Direction it's
going to move our character to the left
or to the right
okay again all this will start to make
sense as we get through the tutorial
there is a lot of stuff I need to do
kind of up front before I can just show
you instantly so hopefully you guys are
following along uh but I just want to
note we eventually of course will see
how all this works I'll walk through the
code so no worries if it's a bit
confusing right now now what else do we
need to do inside of the loop well we
need to update something known as The
Mask which I'm going to get to in a
second but before we can do that we need
to Define uh what's known as our image
so I'm going to say Define and this is
going to be draw and this is going to be
the function that handles drawing on the
screen and for draw we are going to take
in our window which I'll just represent
with win now what we'll do for now is
we'll just say Pi game
dot draw dot rectangle we'll draw the
rectangle on the window which is the
first argument here it's where we're
drawing it the second argument is the
color which is going to be self.color
then the last is the rectangle so I'm
going to say that is self dot rect now
notice the rack tier right has our XY
width height and when we move we're
updating the X and Y of the rectangle
which will then change where we're
drawing it if I can find it here on the
screen
okay so that's what we need for drum now
actually for now I think that's okay
we will add to this obviously in a
second but I think we can generate a
player draw the player see it moving and
then go from there
so let's do that so let's go to main
here
I'm going to create a player
I'm going to say player is equal to
player I need to pass an x a y and a
width and a height so I'm going to pass
let's say a hundred
and let's make him 50 by 50.
and then what we can do now
is pass our player to the draw function
we can then take player inside of here
and we can say player dot draw and we
can pass the window
okay so I will move the player in one
second but for now let's just see if
this is working if it's going to show up
on the screen so let's run the code
and notice that now we have a red
rectangle in the top left hand corner
obviously nothing's happening right now
because we're not moving it around the
screen but you could see it's showing
so we have our player we're drawing the
player on the screen now we want to
start using some of these methods Right
Moving left moving right Etc so I want
to separate my movement into a function
so I'm going to say Define handle move
like this and for this right now we'll
just take in the player
now inside of handle move what we're
going to do is essentially check the
keys that are being pressed on the
keyboard if you're pressing left or
you're pressing right then we'll move
the character to the left or to the
right eventually we will check for
collision and we will do all that so I'm
going to say key is equal to pygame dot
keys
actually not keys.key DOT get underscore
pressed this tells you all of the keys
on the keyboard that are currently being
pressed and I'm going to say if and
actually this is going to be key really
we should call this Keys though because
this makes a bit more sense so we're
going to say if keys and then this is
pygame dot k underscore left this is the
left Arrow key if you wanted to use the
a key then you would use a like that uh
yeah actually I'll go with left Arrow
key because that's what I usually do but
you can use a or swap it however you
want and then I'm going to say if this
is the case then player dot move
underscore left and how much do I want
to move the player bikes we have to pass
the velocity well this is going to be my
player velocity right
okay next I'm going to say if keys and
this is pygame dot k underscore right
then I'm going to say player dot move
underscore right
again same thing I'm going to move this
by my player velocity now it's important
that before I do this I set my player
velocity to be zero now the reason this
is the case is because if I don't do
this what will happen is as soon as I
move left this is going to set my player
velocity right which you can see here my
X Val it's going to set the x velocity
now once I set that I'm going to
continue moving in that direction until
it gets set back to zero so if you
wanted to make it so when you press a
key you just continually move in that
direction until you press a different
key then you could omit this but in our
case we only want to move while you're
holding down the key so I'm going to say
player.xval equals zero there's a lot of
other ways to go about doing this but I
just want to stay consistent with our
movement because of how we're going to
do the gravity so for now just bear with
me we essentially set the velocity to
zero and then if we are moving left or
right so if we're pressing these Keys
then we change the velocity to be you
know the negative player velocity or the
positive player velocity based on the
direction we're moving in okay that's
actually all we need for handling the
movement so let's put the handle
movement function uh where are we going
to put this we're going to put this
before we draw
so I'm going to say handle move I want
to pass my player all right now I need
to make sure before I do this that I
call my Loop function okay and I pass my
FPS and the reason I need to call Loop
is because Loop is what actually moves
my player right
if you look at loop it's moving my
player in the x velocity and Y velocity
direction every single frame so if I set
the x velocity well then I continue
moving again if I set the Y velocity I
move in that direction but that only
works if we're continually calling this
Loop function
okay good so we've made great progress
so far let's see now if we can move our
player or if I've made any mistakes
which are very likely so let's run the
code and let's see okay so I'm going to
hit my right arrow key you can see I can
move to the right and I can move to the
left obviously if I wanted to go up and
down I could Implement that but we want
to have it jumping
which I will show you uh in a second but
we kind of need Collision before we can
do jumping
very good all is looking great so far
now let's Implement gravity so we kind
of fall down then we can do uh kind of
the Sprite sheets then we can do the
Collision because the Collision makes
more sense I guess once we have the uh
the Sprite sheets done so let's
Implement gravity now gravity is a
little bit complicated because we want
to have
um like kind of a realistic gravity
right that actually implements some
basic physics what I mean by that is
rather than just having a constant
velocity we want to actually have an
acceleration for our gravity so as many
of you know if you're in physics gravity
um the acceleration is negative 9.8
meters per second squared I believe
that's what the acceleration is anyway
in our game we want to emulate something
similar to that where it feels like the
longer you're falling the faster you
fall you're not falling at a constant
speed that makes the game just feel like
really really unrealistic so the first
thing we need to do is pick some value
that we want our gravity to be and this
is the acceleration of gravity so keep
that in mind
so for this I'm going to make a variable
in my player class because it's the only
place we need it right now I'm going to
say this equal to one
so gravity is equal to one if you want
gravity to be faster obviously you uh
increment this value right make it large
okay now inside of loop this is where we
need to handle our gravity so every
single frame in our loop we're going to
increase the Y velocity by our gravity
however how we know how much to increase
the velocity by
varies on how long we've been falling
for
again I know this seems really weird but
we essentially need to keep track of how
long we've been falling so that we know
how quickly we should be increasing our
velocity or how quick we should be
accelerating downwards so that means
that I need to create a variable here
called self dot count and given we
should really call this thing better
I'll call it fall count and this will um
essentially tell us okay how long have
we been in the air for how long have we
been falling and we'll use this value to
determine how much we increment our
velocity by so I'm now I'm going to say
myself.y underscore velocity
and I'm going to add to this the minimum
of 1 or and I'm going to take my
self.count and this is my fall count
divided by the frames per second
multiplied by the self.gravity now this
isn't truly what the acceleration would
be but this will give us like a kind of
somewhat realistic looking gravity in
the game so just bear with me here so
what we're doing we're taking our fall
count we're dividing it by FPS the point
of this is that if I want this value to
be in seconds then I need to take
whatever my count is which I'm going to
increment every single Loop in fact
we'll do this right now plus equals one
and I divide it by FPS so if my FPS is
60 as soon as this is 60 then I've been
falling for one second I take that
amount of time I multiply it by my
gravity and then that tells me how much
I'm going to increment my y velocity by
however this is going to start out being
really really small just like fractional
decimal decimal amounts so just to make
this a bit easier for us when we do our
Collision I'm going to increment this by
the minimum of 1 or this value so every
frame we're moving at least one pixel
down and it doesn't take us like a full
second before we really start feeling
any effective gravity
hopefully uh that makes a bit of sense
you guys are understanding me here but
just bear with me I've uh experimented
with these numbers quite a bit so I
think this should be fine
okay so now that we have this what
should happen when I just click run here
is I should just start falling
immediately on the screen and obviously
until we have some platforms or
Collision we can't really stop falling
if we have gravity uh but let's have a
look and let's see how it works right
now
okay so you can see that I've fall and
notice I'll do this again that I start
falling slowly and then it picks up the
pace right so this is somewhat realistic
to how gravity would actually work and
that's what I was trying to implement
when I did this
now that we have done that it's time to
move on and have some kind of Sprites or
images I was going to do this later but
I realized that we can't really do the
Collision which is going to be Pixel
Perfect Collision until we have some
kind of images that's that's really what
we need we need our Sprites so what we
need to do here first is examine what
our Sprites look like for our characters
now remember all these characters pretty
much the exact same they just look
different but in terms of their
movements their animations number of
images they're identical so whatever I
show you for one of these is the same
for all of them hence why we can just
kind of swap them out so when I go to
mask dude here let's zoom in you can see
that we have for example double jumper I
just picked a random Sprite sheet now
this sheet has six different animations
or six different frames which represent
what this guy's going to look like while
he's kind of jumping or double jumping
in the air so what we need to do is we
need to split this one image into the
six individual images and then Loop
through those images at some frequency
or some time so that we can show them on
the screen and show in animation right
we need to kind of manually do this now
some of these are single frames like
falling is just single frame that's easy
hit okay this is um like you know the
guy disappears for a second
kind of expands goes back
you get the point where you want to Loop
through these animations idle single
frame actually no idle is not a single
frame it's a bunch of frames this guy's
arms are kind of wagging up and down we
have jump a single frame run a bunch of
frames and then wall jump now
notice here with these uh images that
they're in different directions or let's
say they're all kind of facing right so
another thing we're going to have to do
is rotate this image to face left when
our character is facing left so that's
another thing we have to handle that not
only do we just have to split these
images up we also have to get a rotated
version of them so we can show you
moving in a different direction same
with jumping same with being idle like
whatever Direction you're going we need
to show the image flipped in that
direction
uh so not rotate sorry flip that's what
we're going to do okay
so let's do this first thing I will do
actually is I'll write the function that
will flip our image
so I'm going to say flip Sprites this is
going to take in a list of Sprites
and I'm going to return
Pi game
dot transform dot flip and this is going
to be Sprite
true false notice as it says here this
is indicating what directions you want
to flip in when I pass true this means
flip in the X Direction when I pass
false this means don't flip in the y
direction if you want to flip both you'd
pass true twice but we don't want to do
that so I have Pi game.transform dot
flip Sprite and then this is going to be
four
bright in Sprites really I could call
this image but
you get the point okay so we have flip
now we're going to write a function
which is load Sprite
sheets and
should we call it sheet or sheets I
think sheets is fine and what this is
going to do is load all of the different
Sprite sheets for our character so it's
going to give us a spreadsheet for
double jumping for hitting for falling
and then within our character we can
pick what sheet we want to be using and
what animations we want to Loop through
so I'm going to take in directory 1 and
directory 2 and the reason I'm doing
this is so that I can load other images
that aren't just my characters and this
will be very dynamic I also want to take
in the desired width and height of my
image
and if we need to load multiple
directions so I'm going to say Direction
equals false as a default parameter so
that we only load like the left and the
right side images like we flip the
images if you pass this equal to true
okay now the first thing we need to do
is determine the path to the images
we're going to be loading so I'm going
to say join assets der 1 dir 2. notice I
can use join because I imported this
from os.path okay now I'm going to get
all of the images in this directory now
the way I do that is a following let's
say images is equal to this is going to
be f for f in list directory again
notice I can use that because I import
it here we're going to list all of the
things that are inside of this path
directory and then we're going to say if
is file and then this is going to be
join path and F
so what this for Loop is going to do
here this uh I forget what you actually
call this when you write a for Loop in a
list anyways what this line is going to
do here is load every single file only
file that is inside of this directory so
again we're just going to get every
single one of these file names and then
once we have those file names we can
load that image and we can then split
that image up into the individual images
that we want
okay so we have images now I'm going to
say
all Sprites is equal to a dictionary and
what I'm going to do with this
dictionary is have key value pairs where
the key is the let's say animation style
and the value is all of the images in
that animation
okay so I have all Sprites and I'm going
to say four image in images
and I'm going to say that my Sprite
sheet so the individual Sprite sheet I
want to load here is going to be equal
to pygame dot image dot load and then
this is going to be join
path and image and then dot convert
Alpha which is essentially going to
allow me to load a transparent
background image okay so we are loading
the image which is just one of the files
that we found right from this path and
we just need to append the path to it
right
so whatever the path to the directory is
plus the image name
okay we're going to load that in we're
going to get the transparent background
now that we have this we need to get all
of the Sprites in this image
so I'm going to say Sprites is equal to
and now this is going to be a list
okay so again the processes load all the
different files
okay we have all the files these are
sprite sheets now we need to get all the
individual images from the Sprite sheet
and load those okay so I'm going to say
4i in range and then this is going to be
Sprite sheet dot get underscore width
integer divided by the width of the
image that we're loading now width is
going to be the width of an individual
image inside of our animation or inside
of our Sprite sheet so if I know this is
say 32 pixels I pass 32 and then it
gives me a bunch of images that are 32
pixels wide that's how I'm doing the
loading because that's why I took width
and height here okay
now that we have that
we're going to say surface
is equal to
Pi game
dot surface and then this is going to be
with
height
we're going to pass pygame DOT s r c
Alpha which allows us to load again
transparent images and then I'm going to
pass 32 here which is the depth don't
worry about that but it's just what we
need to load these images and now we
need to create a rectangle which is
going to tell us where in this image
again image being the Sprite sheet that
we want to take an individual image from
and BLT it onto this surface I know this
seems really weird what we're doing is
we're going to create a surface that's
the size of our desired individual
animation frame we're then going to grab
that animation frame from our main main
image we're going to draw it onto the
surface and then we're going to kind of
export that surface that's the way that
we have to do this
so I'm going to say rectangle is equal
to Pi game
Dot rect and for the rect this is the
location on our original image so we
want to grab this new frame from so I'm
going to say this is I multiplied by my
width and then 0 and then the width and
the height of my image
okay now that I have that I'm going to
say surface.blit blit really means draw
and I'm going to draw my Sprite sheet
but I'm going to draw this at 0 0 and
I'm only going to draw the portion of it
which is my rectangle so notice this is
my source this is the destination and
this is the area of my source that I'm
drawing so in position 0 0 which is the
top left hand corner of my new Surface I
am drawing my Sprite sheet but I'm only
drawing the frame from my Sprite sheet
that I want
okay then I'm going to say Sprite start
append and I'm going to append my
Surface but I'm going to make my Surface
Two Times larger because that's what I
want to do I want this to be bigger than
the default size so I'm going to say Pi
game Dot
transform dot scale to X and then I'm
going to scale 2x my Surface
okay
again I know this seems a bit
complicated but now we have essentially
stripped out all the individual frames
we've just scaled them up to be double
their size so if they're 32 by 32 we've
made them 64 by 64 that's what scale 2x
does and now we need to handle the
directions
okay so now we need to say
if Direction then all underscore Sprites
and this is going to be image
dot replace it's going to be dot PNG
this is going to be an empty string plus
underscore right is equal to our Sprites
then we're going to copy the same thing
let's copy this and put it here and now
this is going to be underscore left is
equal to
and this is going to be flip
Sprites
so what we're saying here is if you want
a multi-directional animation then we
need to add two keys to our dictionary
here for every single one of our
animations so for falling for hit for
idle we need a left and a right side so
the right side is the one that we
already have so we're going to say okay
all Sprite at and then we're just going
to strip off the dot PNG from whatever
the name of our base image was so that's
going to give us run jump idle hit
whatever the name of our files and then
we're going to append underscore write
or underscore left now for underscore
right that's our basic Sprites for
underscore left we need to flip all of
those Sprites and we already wrote the
function that did that now otherwise
then what we'll do is say all underscore
Sprites at image dot replace
dot PNG
with an empty string this just removes
the dot PNG
and then it's going to be equal
two Sprites
okay
then we can return
all of our Sprites
all right probably one of the most
complicated aspects of the code that we
need to write so don't worry we are done
now with loading images at least we'll
have to load our block but that's going
to be a lot easier than loading our
Sprite sheets so this now will load a
Sprite shoot for us now that we've
loaded our Sprite sheet we actually want
to start using this so inside of player
we are going to grab our images so I'm
going to say my Sprites is equal to and
it's going to be load Sprite sheets and
now I need to pass what I want to load
so now I need to pass the main character
directory and actually this is the main
characters
okay so have a look here so inside of
assets right uh yes so we're joining
assets with dur1 and dirt two so the
first directory I pass is main
characters and then I pass the second
directory which is the name of the
character I want to load so mask dude
ninja frog pink men or virtual guy you
can pick whatever one you want I'm gonna
go with mask dude for now now for width
and height uh the width and the height
of this is going to be 32. so make sure
you do this 3232 and then you pass true
because we want a multi-directional
Sprite so both the left and right side
animations that's what we want okay
now that we have that we are going to
change our draw here so that we're
drawing our Sprite now for for now we're
just going to draw like one simple
Sprite just so you see how it looks on
the screen then I'll go through
animating the Sprite and showing you how
that works
okay so rather than pygame.draw.rect I'm
going to say self.sprite is equal to and
then this is going to be
self dot Sprites at idle now idle is one
of the name of our animations right so
if we go here you can see we have idle
jump Etc so I'm accessing the key from
my dictionary and then I'm going to
access the first frame of this key which
is zero because every single key is a
whole like Sprite sheet right so now
that I have my Sprite
I'm going to say win.blit and then this
is going to be self.sprite and I'm going
to blip this at
self.rec.x and self.rec Dot Y which is
the position on the screen and then if
we want we can just turn off the gravity
for right now so we can kind of see it
on the screen and it doesn't just
disappear okay let's try this out let's
just make sure it actually loaded
correctly so let me run this and we got
an error okay so let me see what error
we got here
um
run this again
it said key key error idle okay so the
issue here is that since we load a
directional Sprite we need to reference
either idle right or idle left so we can
actually do this by saying idle
underscore Plus
self
dot Direction and then so long as we set
the direction which we did here to left
uh this should work so now it'll change
based on if we're going left or right so
actually you'll see that it should swap
as we change directions okay let's try
this now
all right so now we have this guy facing
left if I go right
he turns right left right
perfect now we want to see him animated
so as I was saying let's get into the
animation now this is actually going to
be pretty easy because we've already
loaded in all of the frames that we need
so I know that we don't have a ton to
show right now but a lot of the hard
stuff is done for this video so just
making you aware that all this time has
not gone to waste what we need to do is
we need to come up with something that
has a way to kind of update our Sprite
or update what we're showing on the
screen so I'm going to write a function
here called update
Sprite
and I'm going to take in self
and I'm going to say Sprite sheet
is equal to idle now this is the default
Sprite sheet if we're not moving if
we're not jumping if we're not falling
if we're not being attacked we use item
however if we are running or we're doing
something else then we use the other
spreadsheet so now I'm going to say if
my self.x velocity does not equal zero
then my Sprite sheet is going to be
equal to run so if I have some velocity
in the X Direction then I'm running
right so then I want to change this to
the Run spreadsheet so now I'm going to
say my Sprite sheet name
is equal to and this is going to be my
Sprite sheet plus and then underscore
and then plus the self dot Direction
perfect so now we just change the main
Sprite sheet name so idle run jump
whatever we add the direction to it and
this tells us you know what exact Sprite
shoot we want
okay now that we have that what we're
going to do is say these Sprites that we
could be using for this animation is
equal to self.sprites and this is in all
capitals at the Sprite sheet name
all right now that we've done that we
need to essentially iterate through
these Sprites and every few seconds
change the Sprite that we're showing so
it looks like we're animating so we need
to add a variable here that is going to
account for the amount of delay between
changing Sprites so I'm going to call
this the animation delay I'm going to
make this equal to five okay now I'm
going to come here and I'm going to say
that my Sprite index which essentially a
Sprite that I want to be using here is
equal to my self.animation count which
we're going to increment in a second
integer divided by myself.animation
delay
modulus by the length of these Sprites
that I'm using now let's just put
some parentheses here for order of
operations
and let me explain what we're doing so
we have an animation delay that's every
five frames so every five frames I want
to show a different Sprite in whatever
animation we're using so for running
left if we're idle whatever it doesn't
matter we want to show a different one
so we take the animation count we divide
it by five and then we mod whatever the
line of our Sprites is so if we have
five Sprites then when we're on say
animation count 10 we're showing the
second Sprite right you get the idea so
this is dynamic this will now work for
any single Sprite so hopefully you guys
understand how this animation count is
kind of working but we're just trying to
pick a new index every animation frames
from our uh Sprites but we want this to
be dynamic so we're using the length of
the Sprites and again it's just it's
dynamical work for any single Sprite
sheet we have now we need to select our
Sprites we say self dot Sprite is equal
to the Sprites that we have access to at
the Sprite index then we update our
animation count by one
now what we can do is remove this here
from draw and we just need to Now call
the self Dot
update sprite from our Loop okay so now
that we've done that we'll call this
we'll update our Sprite every single
frame and then we'll draw that updated
Sprite on the screen
okay let's run it and let's see what we
get
notice we have idle notice I can run to
the right and I can run to the left now
if you think this is too slow and some
of you may argue that it is then you
just make this number smaller so make
this three
okay and now it looks like we're running
a little bit faster so it's completely
up to you how you want to animate this
um I'll do two for now and let's see if
this looks better
so actually I think three was a pretty
kind of happy medium here since go back
to three again you guys can change this
it's up to you how you want it to look
okay now that we have that
we are almost ready to start doing
Collision however we need to introduce
something known as a mask so I'm going
to make another method here I'm going to
say Define update
now what we need to do here is
essentially update the rectangle that
bounds our character based on the Sprite
that we're showing so there's different
um like kind of sizes to the Sprites
right some are a little bit taller some
are a little push to the left or pushed
to the right and the rectangle that we
have we want to be essentially the same
as the Sprite that we have again I know
this seems a bit weird but we're gonna
do this we're gonna say self.rect is
equal to self Dot and then this is going
to be Sprite dot get underscore rect and
we're going to say that the top left of
this rectangle is equal to the self.rect
dot X
and the self.rec dot y
now pretty much what's going to happen
here is depending on what Sprite image
we have if it's slightly smaller
slightly bigger whatever we're going to
constantly adjust the rectangle
specifically we're going to adjust the
width and the height of it but we're
going to use the same X and Y position
that we've had for this rectangle if you
don't understand that
um it's fine it's not a massive deal
this line is not crazy important but
it's just trying to make sure that the
rectangle we're using to kind of bound
our character is constantly adjusted
based on the Sprite that we're using now
what's more important is this line which
is updating the mask we're going to say
self.mask is equal to pygame dot mask
Dot from surface and this is going to be
self.spray
now let me quickly explain this a mask
is essentially a mapping of all of the
pixels that exist in the Sprite so
whenever we draw something on the screen
we're really drawing a rectangle right
but the rectangle may not have
um non-transparent pixels right so only
part of the rectangle is actually filled
in hence why we get kind of a circular
image a dynamic image whatever so what
this mask tells us is where there's
actually images or where's this actually
pixels sorry and this mask allows us to
perform Pixel Perfect Collision because
we can overlap it with another mask and
make sure that we only say two objects
Collide if pixels are colliding not if
the rectangular box is colliding if we
did rectangular Collision then it
constantly looks like we're hitting
something even when we're not because
the rectangle for our character is
larger than where all of the pixels for
our character are you've probably seen
this in a lot of games before but what
the mask does is solve that problem for
us and allow us to do this kind of Pixel
Perfect Collision it's very important
though that you call this mask if you
don't do that this Collision is not
going to work properly it needs to be
masked because the Sprite that we
inherited from here uses this rectangle
and uses this mask property when it does
the Collision all right so now that
we've done this I just need to call this
function so I'm going to go here and say
self dot update and now we're done with
most of what we need for the player
so what we want to do now is we want to
start adding blocks onto the screen and
then letting a player fall collide with
those blocks and then be able to jump
because obviously we can't really jump
until we have something to jump off of
otherwise jumping in thin air doesn't
make a ton of sense all right so let's
create another class here and this class
I'm going to call object and this will
be a base class that we use for
essentially all of our objects just so
that the Collision will be uniform
across all of them so again we're going
to inherit from the Sprite class from PI
game and we're going to Define our
initialization so Define a knit we're
going to take in self X Y width and
height and name which for now is going
to be equal to none but could be equal
to something we're then going to say
super dot underscore underscore knit
which will initialize the superclass
which is this one right here now that
reminds me we need this as well in our
Constructor for player so let's put that
in player
okay now we need to define a rectangle
so we're going to say self-direct angle
is equal to Pi game
Dot rect
and then this is going to be x y
width and height
we're going to say self.image is equal
to Pi game
dot surface and then this is going to be
width
height and then we're going to say Pi
game
dot source
Alpha like that if we spell Pi game
correctly again this just supports
transport transparent images for us my
apologies and then we're going to say
self dot width equals width
self.height
is equal to height and self dot name
is equal to name
where are they going to say Define draw
I'm going to say self and window like
this and then we're going to say win
dot Blitz
and this is going to be self.image
and then we're going to blip this at the
self.rect
dot X and the self.rect dot y
okay I know I went fast essentially this
is just a base class we're not actually
going to instantiate this but this just
defines all the properties that we need
for a valid Sprite so we have a
rectangle we have our image we are
drawing the image and then in a class
that we're about to use we're going to
inherit from this and it will just save
us from rewriting a bunch of
functionality that we don't need so the
idea here is that all we do is modify
this image when we change the image now
the draw function will automatically
draw it accurately on the screen for us
and all these other properties we're
just saving in case we need them from
our child class so I'm going to make a
class now called block this is going to
inherit from object
now we're going to say Define
a net and we're going to take in self x
y and the size of our block now since
the block is a square we just need one
dimension not two right
okay we're going to say super
dot underscore underscore knit
and we're going to pass x y
size size so notice this Constructor
requires four arguments so we have to
pass four here we just duplicate size
because it's the same for the width and
the height then we're going to say block
is equal to load block which is going to
be a function that we write in a second
that will take a size we're then going
to say self dot image dot blit
imagine that this is going to give us an
image okay which it will in a second
when we write it we're going to blit the
block
at position zero zero and then we're
going to say the self.mask is equal to
Pi game
dot mask Dot from surface we're going to
take our self dot image and there you go
we have our mask which we need for
Collision
okay again I know this is a little
confusing it'll make more sense in a
second but we're using this object which
now has this draw function built in for
us it also defines the rack that defines
the width and the height and all of that
stuff here what we do is we get the
image that we need which we're going to
write this in one second then we BLT
this image to our image which is a pi
game surface and then we say self.maski
we'll do pogame.mask.f from surface self
dot image we also could just say
self.image is equal to the block but
let's do it this way for now okay so
let's now write our get Block function
which I'm going to do beneath our get
Sprite sheet or load Sprite sheet so I'm
going to say get Block
and I'm going to take in a size now what
I need to do here is essentially find
the block that I want in my train folder
so I'm going to say path is equal to
join
assets and then this is going to be
terrain like so and then we're going to
use the terrain.png file so if I go here
you can see that we have train terrain
and then what we want to do is load this
block
which I'll be showing you how to load in
one second
okay
now that we have done that now that we
have our path we're going to say the
image is equal to Pi game dot image dot
load and we're going to say path again
dot convert Alpha so that we get a
transparent background we don't really
need it for this one but just in case
later we load string does have
transparency we will
and then we're going to say surface is
equal to Pi game dot surface and for the
surface we're going to pass size size
which is the width and the height of our
surface
we're gonna pass pygame DOT Source Alpha
with a depth sorry of 32. we're going to
say rectangle is equal to pygame Dot
rect and then this is going to be 96 0
size size now let me slow down for one
second if we go to Terrain
we can see that we want to load this guy
right here now I've already done the
math this image starts 96 pixels from
the top of the screen so that's the
reason I'm putting 96 there because I
want to start at 96 so 960 is my
position and then I want to load the
size of this which I think is going to
be either 96 or 64 or something along
those lines anyways if I wanted to load
say this terrain image then I would
still have 96 but my y position would be
different in fact the Y position would
probably be a little bit less than 96 it
might be 80 it might be 85 I'd have to
like experiment with it to see exactly
where this image starts but I just want
you to understand that what I'm passing
here when I say something like 960 I'm
passing the position that I want to load
the image from from the image right so
I'm picking out a part of this image and
this is like 960. that's why I'm picking
it right here
hopefully uh you guys understand that
but if you want to load a different
train image then you have to adjust
these to be the starting position the
top left hand corner of whatever image
it is you want to load here and if yeah
I was going to say we could load
different one but I don't want to waste
time guessing which one it is so you
guys can mess with that if you want but
let's just load this top one which I
already know works okay now that we have
that we're gonna say surface dot blit
and we're going to Blitz the image
and again we're going to blend it at 0
0.
but we're only going to blit the area of
it which is represented by the rectangle
then we're going to return highgame Dot
transform dot scale 2X
surface
Okay so we've passed what size we want
our block to be
then we create an image that is of that
size okay we then say rectangle is equal
to 96 0 size size right and then we BLT
this image onto our surface which will
be the image that we return and we
return this scaled up by two times so it
just doubles the size that we pass here
you don't have to scale it if you don't
want but I want it to be larger so I am
scaling it now I understand again it's a
bit confusing this size is going to be
the dimension of this block so you want
to pass whatever the size from this
Sprite sheet is that you want to get in
our case I think it's going to be 64 or
something along those lines so that's
what size will be
you guys can mess around with this but
really what you're going to be changing
is these two values and the size that's
what you're going to change when you
want to load a different image for your
block okay so now for Block we have get
block or load block uh did I call it
load block or get Block
I called it get Block okay so let's
change this to be get Block
all right so we now have our block let's
create a block let's draw a block on the
screen and let's do some collision with
our blocks
okay so let's go here to Main
and let's say blocks is equal to
and let's just start by creating a
single block so for our block uh let's
just put it kind of randomly on the
screen for now uh where do I want to put
this let's go with something like
actually I'm going to create a variable
first I'm going to say block size let's
put this at zero
height minus the block underscore size
block size is going to be equal to 96
okay and then four
the size we're going to pass block size
okay
so the size of our block is actually 96
I lied it is not 64. it's going to be
96. so we're going to create a block
it's gonna be positioned at zero height
minus block size which is going to put
it at the bottom of the screen and then
the size is this now we need to draw our
blocks so I'm going to pass blocks to my
draw function
okay and I'm going to go here
and actually let's call this objects
and we're going to say form objects or
for obj
in objects if we could type this
correctly
obj dot draw I'm struggling here with
the typing and we will draw this on the
window
okay so we have our block now
let's quickly look at this again right
we load our image okay we get our block
we have our size now we create the block
down here
and then we put it on the screen
let's run it and let's see if we got a
block
and of course we've got an error what
does it say here I need to run this
again
I take zero positional arguments but one
was given okay so let's go to our player
class here
and we can see update I forgot to add
the self parameter so let's add that in
and that should fix it
okay so now you can see that we have a
block so now what we can do is create a
whole floor of blocks if we want to do
that and then we'll Implement gravity
and then collision with the block so
that you can see that you like can land
on the Block and we can jump off of the
block
all right so let's make a whole floor so
to make a floor we can do this we're
going to say floor is equal to we're
going to say block
it's going to be I
times
block size
it's going to be height minus block size
4 I in range and I'm going to say
negative width
width times two
um and we're going to divide this
by the block size
and by the block size
okay then for my
blocks uh let's actually just
replace this and instead we'll just pass
floor
okay what I've done here with this for
Loop is I've said I want to create
blocks that go kind of to the left and
to the right of the screen so I don't
want to just fill the current screen
because we're going to have a scrolling
background in a second which we'll
Implement in a minute anyways I want to
have some kind of going to the left and
some going to the right so I'm taking my
negative width uh over the block size
which is how many blocks I want to the
left side of the screen and then I'm
taking my width times 2 and I'm instant
dividing that by the block size again
that's how many blocks I want to the
right of the screen then I'm taking I
I'm multiplying it by my block size
which is telling me the x coordinate
position that I want my block to be at
and then this is always going to be the
same because I want it to be at kind of
the bottom of the screen and then for my
block size well I want that to always be
the same
okay so let's run this now and see what
we get
and now we get a bunch of blocks so now
that we have these blocks let's make it
so we can collide with the blocks and so
we have gravity and we actually fall
onto those blocks
so the Collision all right Collision is
a little complicated but
let's write it and let's see how we can
how we can get it going here so inside
of handle move is where we're going to
handle our Collision which means we need
to have a list of objects that we can
potentially be colliding with now we are
going to write a function here
called handle vertical
Collision because we need to handle the
vertical and horizontal Collision
differently for now we'll just start
with uh vertical now we're going to take
in player objects and the displacement
in y that we just moved
now we're going to have collided
underscore objects is equal to a list
we're going to say for object in
objects these are all the objects we
could be colliding with and we're going
to say if Pi game
Dot Sprite dot Collide mask and then
we're going to pass
our player
and our object
now remember I told you Collision was
going to be simple well there you go
this is all you need to do to determine
if two objects are colliding the reason
we can do this is because our objects
we've inherited from the Sprite class
and on them we have a mask so we're
going to use this mask property as well
as the rectangle property when we
collide with the mask so I pass my
player I pass my object and this will
tell me if I am colliding with my object
perfect now if I am I'm going to do some
stuff differently depending on what
direction I'm colliding in so if I'm
hitting the top of the object it's going
to be different than if I'm hitting the
bottom so we need to handle that here so
I'm going to say if my displacement Y is
greater than zero really this should be
velocity about this fine
then what I'm going to do is place
my character on top of the object it
collided with so I'm no longer colliding
with
now what this is saying is if I'm moving
down on the screen so if I'm moving down
then that would mean I was colliding
with the top of this object so if I am
I'm going to take the bottom of my
player rectangle which is my bottom my
player's feet essentially and I'm going
to make it equal to the top of the
object I'm colliding with this is
another advantage of using rectangles
you can use this kind of bottom and top
property and avoid having to do you know
add the height and all that kind of
stuff so that's what I'm going to do now
otherwise I'm going to say if my
displacement Y is less than zero and I
suppose this can be an L if
then
what I will do is say myplayer.rec dot
top is equal to the obj.rec dot bottom
because if I'm moving up which means I
have a negative velocity then I am
hitting the bottom of an object so I
need to make my top be equal to the
bottom okay this just makes it so you
don't like say stay inside of the object
excuse me you go outside of it and it
looks like you collided but you didn't
go through the object
now one thing we also need to do here is
you need to call the methodplayer.landin
player.hitthead which I've not yet
created and we're going to write these
to handle what happens when we land on a
block and when we hit our head on a
block
okay then we're going to say collided
objects dot append and we're going to
append our object and we're going to
return our collided objects just so that
we know what objects we collide with so
that we can check if we collided with
like fire or a certain special object or
something like that
okay so that's handle vertical Collision
now we need to write the landed and hit
head method
so let's go to player
and let's do this so I'm going to say
let's do it here
landed
self
now what do we do if we lend it well if
we just landed then we need to reset our
gravity or our fall counter
so we're going to say self dot fall
count
is equal to zero so that way we stop
um like adding gravity right okay what
else do we need to do if we land it we
need to say that our y velocity
is equal to zero if we let it on a block
stop moving us down
and I'll add this in now we're going to
say our self.jump count is equal to zero
we're going to do something with jumping
that involves double jumping so we'll
have a jump counter I'll just put this
here now and then we'll we'll use it
later
okay so that's if we landed otherwise
I'm going to say Define
hit head
for self I'm going to say self.count
equals zero but if we hit our head I
want to reverse our velocity so that now
we move down because we're moving up
right so I'm going to multiply my
velocity by negative one so when I hit
my head I kind of bounce off the block
and go downwards that's what's going to
look most natural
okay so that's all we need for right now
for hitting the head now we can add our
gravity back and when we add our gravity
back what's going to happen is we'll
fall we'll hit the block it'll move us
to the top of the block
and then we should just be able to move
on top of the block
let's see if that's going to work though
uh although it's not going to work if we
don't add the function call so let's add
the function call here
in handle move we're going to say
handle vertical Collision we'll pass the
player the objects
and the player.y velocity
and the Y velocity is essentially how
much we just moved right
okay very good now let's make sure
handle move we need to pass our floor so
let's do that
all right let's run the code
let's see what we get
and boom look we land on a block and we
can now run on top of the block
and everything is looking very good to
me okay so that's pretty good now that
we're on top of a block we can jump and
then we can deal with uh hitting blocks
um what do you call this uh horizontally
right so that we can't like run into a
block and we'll also make the background
scroll and then we'll be pretty good
we'll have a lot of this tutorial
finished
I wanted to make us jump yes let's make
a jump okay so let's go to our player
and let's create a variable here
self.jump underscore count is equal to
zero now based on the way of coded this
jumping is actually quite easy I can say
Define
jump
self and when we jump all we're going to
do is say self.y underscore velocity is
equal to the negative of self-dog
gravity multiplied by whatever Factor
you want in terms of the speed of your
jump so I'm going to multiply Gravity by
eight the reason I'm doing this negative
is that I jump up in the air right so
now that I've done this what will happen
is as soon as I hit the jump key I'll
jump up into the air it's pretty
straightforward and the reason that's
going to happen is because my y velocity
will change and what will bring me down
is the fact that inside of my Loop if I
go to where Loop is I'm constantly
applying downward gravity so what I'm
doing is changing my velocity to go
upwards and then I'm letting gravity
take me down so that's kind of the
benefit of how we've coded this jumping
is very easy
now I'm also going to reset my animation
count to zero I'm going to say my jump
count plus equals one I'm going to say
if the self dot jump underscore count
is equal to one this means that I'm
double jumping so if the jump Count's
equal to one when I hit jump that means
it's just going to be equal to 2 now
actually let me take this sorry and put
this down here
then I will say self.count is equal to
zero
I think
does that make sense
no I want to do it this way sorry okay
so what I'm trying to do here is make it
so that as soon as I jump I essentially
get rid of any gravity I've already
obtained so let's say I was like falling
and then I landed and then I jumped
there would be some gravity on me
keeping me on the ground so I want to
remove that gravity so that when I jump
up it's not in the factor it's like it's
not taken into account and then I'll
start applying the gravity after I've
jumped hopefully that makes a bit of
sense but this should say
fall count so as soon as I jump I'm
resetting the fall count to be equal to
zero so that any gravity I've
accumulated I'm removing but I'm only
doing that if this is the first jump I'm
making because for the second jump I
want you to have to time it based on
like when you're jumping right so if you
jump a second time close to when you
jump the first time you will jump higher
than if you jumped at like the peak of
your jump when your gravity would be the
highest okay I don't know if that makes
sense but just just follow along here
this I messed with this before this
works trust me
all right so we have jumping now I think
that's all we really need for jumping
um yeah that seems good to me so now if
we want to jump let's make it so when we
hit space we jump so we can do that
inside of handle move
actually I'm not going to do a handle
move I'm going to do it here in the
event Loop and the reason for this is
that if I do it in handle move what's
going to happen is if I press the jump
key and I hold the jump key down I'm
going to keep jumping a bunch of times I
don't want to do that I just want to
jump once when I hit the key and then I
have to release the key and press it
again to jump this tells me if I'm
holding down the key what I'm going to
do in here tells me if I released the
key yeah you'll see
um but yeah this is this is how I do it
so I'm going to say if event DOT type is
equal to pygame Dot key down I'm going
to say if event dot key is equal to
pygame
dot k underscore space
and
my player dot jump count is less than
two so I'm going to allow double jumping
right so I'll have two jumps then I'm
going to say player dot jump
okay
that should be all we need for jumping
so let's try it out and let's see if
this works
and I can jump
and notice I can kind of Run and Jump at
the same time now what I'll do now is
add like falling and jumping animations
because obviously it looks kind of weird
right now when I'm jumping
but there you go we can jump nice
okay so let's add the uh the animations
now so if we go to update Sprite all we
need to do here is we need to say if
self Dot
and actually I need to refer to my cheat
sheet here because this is a bit more
complicated than I thought okay I'm
going to say if not self if self.y
underscore velocity does not equal zero
then what I will do is say if self dot
jump count equals equals one
then I'm going to say my Sprite sheet is
equal to jump
I'm going to say l if self
dot jump count
equals equals two then my spreadsheet
is equal
to double jump
now this is actually going to be if my
velocity is less than zero which means
I'm moving up now the next one that I
want to add is I want to say if and
actually these are all going to be L IFS
well not that one but this one I'm going
to say l if myself dot y underscore Val
is greater than zero this means I'm
moving down then my Sprite sheet should
be equal to fall
okay
so this is handling regular jump and
double jump and this is telling me if
I'm falling let's try it now
and let's see what happens when I jump
okay so it's kind of glitching a little
bit uh the reason this is happening I
believe is because we are applying
gravity even while we're on the ground
so my y velocity
is always greater than zero and then
stop streaming greater than zero that's
greater than zero again so I will show
you how to fix this all right so
actually the way that I'm going to fix
this is a bit of a hack but it's it's
gonna be good it'll work here so I'm
actually going to say if myself the Y
velocity is greater than self
dots
gravity
times two now the reason I'm going to do
this for fall is so that I don't
immediately start glitching into this
fall State when I have a really low
amount of gravity being applied to me
when I've gone off the block and then
I've fallen down to the block so let me
show you what I mean by just kind of
kind of running the code here so you can
see that what happens is when I hit the
block when I collide with it it's going
to reset my gravity count and then I'm
going to kind of Spawn to the top of the
block so when I'm on the top of the
block I'm going to be slowly falling
down to the block then I'm going to hit
the block when I hit the Block it's
going to do the same thing it's going to
bring me to the top reset my gravity
account so what was happening before is
that we would go to the top of the block
and then our gravity would increase a
tiny bit right it increase to be one
pixel per second or something along
those lines which would mean we were
falling so then we were falling we hit
the block and then it reset it so it
kept glitching between the two states so
what I've done is just made it so we
have to have a significant amount of
gravity before it starts showing that
fall state so now it doesn't look
glitchy on the screen as I'm jumping
around
and you can see that what actually
happens is when I jump and I get to the
peak of my jump you can see that it
starts the falling State because
now my velocity has changed directions
right now I'm going down
okay so now we have jumping now we have
running around and colliding with blocks
done quite a bit actually the next thing
I want to do is make it so that objects
move on the screen then we will do our
horizontal collision and then we will
pretty much be done uh after I add kind
of that like fire uh state right or that
let's call it a trap something like that
okay so we want to do scrolling
background scrolling background is
actually fairly easy the way that we do
a scrolling background is we simply
offset every single thing that we're
drawing on the screen by a certain
amount so any object that we have we
don't change its position at all we just
change how we're drawing it on the
screen so it doesn't affect any of our
Collision all it affects is what's seen
right so what's happening in the
background is we may be colliding at a
really far position to the right but
we're showing the position currently on
the screen
you see what I mean but what this
involves
is having some offset X which I'm going
to say is equal to zero now the way that
I want to have it and I'll just
illustrate here is that when I'm on the
screen I only start scrolling the
background when I get close to the edge
so like here right it would start
scrolling whereas if I'm in the middle
and I'm kind of moving like this I don't
want it to scroll the background until I
get to the edge oh also notice you can
double jump here I kind of forgot to to
mention that part
um so I'm going to implement that where
essentially once we reach a certain
boundary then the screen will start
scrolling
all right so how do we do this well we
can do it just directly inside of our
Loop here and we're going to do it here
we're going to say if the player dot
rect dot X
minus the offset X
plus the player.rect dot width and
actually now that I think of this we're
just going to do this we're going to say
if the player.rect dot right which will
account for the width minus the offset X
is greater than or equal to
the width
minus a variable that I'm going to write
in a second which is scroll area
width and the blair.x underscore
velocity is greater than zero
then we're going to say
offset underscore X and this is going to
be plus equals the player dot x velocity
all right let me just write this
variable then I'll explain how this
works because we also have to do the
other side so I'm going to say scroll
area width is equal to 200. what that
means is that when I get to 200 pixels
on the left or 200 pixels on the right
of the screen I start scrolling okay so
here what I'm doing is I'm checking if
I'm moving to the right that's what this
checks if my x velocity is greater than
zero that means I'm moving to the right
and this is checking if my character is
right on the screen like if it's crossed
a specific boundary
so I take whatever the right position of
my player is which could be very far off
the screen
I subtract whatever offset we currently
have so if we're offsetting everything
by 100 pixels for example I subtract
that so I know where I'm actually
showing the character on the screen and
I say if that's greater than the width
minus the scroll area width which means
I'm at say 700 pixels something like
that on the right side of the screen
then I'm going to offset the screen by
whatever the velocity was that my player
just moved to the right so that will
make it look like I'm scrolling now we
can say or
and do the exact same thing for the left
side so I'm going to say if player Dot
rect
dot left
and this is actually going to be
is going to be plus the offset I get to
check if it's Plus or if it's minus no
it's going to be minus again minus the
offset X is less than or equal to the
scroll area width
and my player dot X underscore Val is
less than zero
then I want to do this now let's move
this down on the screen a bit and I'm
just going to add some parentheses so
that my condition is
correct here
okay so I think that should be good
again I'm checking to the left and to
the right side if I'm moving to the left
I want to check if I'm at that boundary
if I'm checking to the right or if I'm
moving to the right sorry I want to
check if I'm at that boundary and then I
increment my offset X now all I have to
do to account for this is add an offset
X to my draw function and draw every
single object offset by this x so I'm
going to go here and say offset
underscore X and now just to all of my
draw functions I'm going to pass
offset X
offset underscore X I'm going to go to
all my draw functions and I'm going to
add this
offset X and what I'm going to do is
just subtract the offset X from the X
position I'm drawing everything out so
I'm going to say minus offset X and
we'll take in
the offset underscore X
okay now the reason this works if I move
to the left my offset X is going to be
negative which means everything is going
to push to the right side because we're
adding to the position for it if I move
to the left side or sorry if I move to
the right side the offset X is going to
be positive which means everything is
going to move to the left so it has a
scrolling background effect
let's just run it though and see if it
works then I can fix it if it doesn't
okay so as I start running here you can
see that now the floor is going to start
going with me once I reach this boundary
however
on this side right like when I'm in the
middle it's not doing anything I have to
get to a certain boundary which is kind
of invisible on the screen and then it
starts scrolling with me which is what I
wanted to do and then notice if I jump
here boom I fall off the platform
let's do collision with blocks in the
horizontal Direction
so to do that I'm just going to add a
block here so I'm actually going to make
a list
I'm going to say objects is equal to
Asterix floor now if you've ever seen uh
like kind of dot dot dot in JavaScript
that's what this does in Python it just
essentially breaks this floor into all
its individual elements and passes them
inside of this list so imagine it if me
just writing this here that's what it's
doing
and then I'm going to pass another block
and for this block I'm going to place
this at
let's do zero and then for the Y this is
going to be the height of the screen
minus the block size times two
now the reason I'm multiplying this by 2
is so that I get it a bit higher on the
screen
so that we can kind of run into it
horizontally and then I'm going to pass
my block size
so I'll just see now I want to go and
rather than drawing my floor
I want to pass objects
and same here with handle move want to
pass objects
so let me run this
so now you can see that I have that
block there right
now notice that when I hit the block I
kind of go to the top of it and the
reason I go to the top of the block is
because right now I'm only handling my
vertical Collision so when I hit the
block I have a little bit of gravity
because remember there's always some
gravity on me when I'm on the floor and
so it thinks that I've hit the top of
the block so it spawns me on the top of
the block so we need to make it now so
that when you hit the Block in the
horizontal Direction it kind of Pops you
off of it so that it doesn't think
you're hitting the top of the block or
the bottom of the block alternatively
which you'll see in a second and in fact
let me add one more block to show you uh
hitting our head on the Block
so let's add another block
let's make this at say block size
multiplied by three and then for the
height let's do times four
okay now we have another block let's see
where this guy is now I can show you
that I can hit my head on the Block
right and I can't kind of go
above it
okay anyways we have that let's do our
horizontal Collision
so the horizontal Collision
is a bit weird to implement the idea
behind this is that since we're using
our Sprite Collide mask we want to make
sure that if we collide with a block
horizontally we move ourselves off of
that block so that it doesn't think that
we're colliding with it in the vertical
Direction now you just saw that happen
we hit the block it thought that we were
hitting it like the top of the block so
it put us on the top of the block
because that's what this line does right
here so in our horizontal Collision we
essentially need to check okay by moving
in this direction are you going to hit
the block if you are going to hit the
block we want to prevent you from moving
in that direction so that you don't
hit it collide with it and then we like
spawn to the top of it
so let me write it and I'll explain to
you how it works but it's just very
important that we check the horizontal
Collision first then once we check that
we check the vertical Collision because
we only want to check vertical Collision
if we are not colliding with a block
horizontally
or if we haven't already handled or if
we have already handled the horizontal
Collision again the idea is we don't
want to be thinking that we're hitting
the block on the top when really we hit
it on the left or the right side so we
got to check that first
so I'm going to make a function I'm
going to say define collide
I'm going to take player objects a
displacement X like that now I'm going
to say player.move
and I'm going to move my player in the
displacement X Direction and zero in the
y direction the reason I'm doing this is
I want to check if with the current
velocity that my player has
if
now the reason I'm doing this is I want
to check if my player were to move to
the right or if they were to move to the
left would they hit a block that's
that's what I'm checking essentially by
moving the player preemptively
so now what I need to do is say
player.update now the reason I need to
call that update and let's go here to
dot update is because I need to update
the rectangle in The Mask before I check
for Collision so again what I'm doing is
I'm preemptively moving my player to
where they would be moving if they're
going left or right I'm updating their
mask and their rectangle and then I'm
going to say for object
in objects if pygame dot Sprite dot
Collide mask
and then I'm passing my player
and my object so this is why I needed to
update my mask and my rectangle so I
move my player I update it and then
using that updated mask I check would I
be colliding with an object now I'm
going to say collided
object
is equal to none
I've got to spell collided correctly
if I am then I'm going to say collided
and this is just going to be object
is equal to obj
then I'm going to break okay then I'm
going to say player.move and I'm going
to move them back
and then I'm going to say
player.update
okay and then I'm going to return the
collided object
okay so what I'm doing right I'm moving
my player I'm updating the mask I'm
checking if they would collide with
something if they were to move in that
direction then if they did okay I get
that Clyde object it doesn't matter if
they do or they don't after I check this
Collision I have to move them back to
where they originally were so I have to
reverse the movement
and then update the mask again
then I return collided object
okay again moving checking if we hit
anything either way moving back to where
we were before this is preemptively
checking before we allow them to move
into a block
all right now what we need to do is use
this function uh to allow us to move
left or right or to disallow us from
moving left or right so I'm going to say
Collide underscore left is equal to
collide
player objects and then negative player
Vel then I'm going to say Collide
underscore right is equal to collide
player objects and then player and then
I'm going to say and not Collide left
and not Collide right
again what we're doing here is we're
checking if we should be able to move
left or if we should be able to move
right uh based on our current position
that's why I make that preemptive
movement and then here I only let you
make the movement if that movement does
not cause you moving into a block or
colliding with one
now that we have that that should
actually handle our horizontal Collision
that's actually all we need
all right so let me run this code and
let's see so I'm here okay obviously
that's still working and you can see
that I can't go through the block now
let's go here and actually I'm getting a
bit of a bug on the right side okay so
that time it worked but it's a little
bit glitchy and I have a feeling it has
to do with the animation count of me
running because it's only sometimes when
I'm running and I hit the block that it
spawns me up here so I'm just going to
do another little hack here and I'm just
going to multiply this by two both of
them here the reason for this being that
I'll just make it so there's a little
bit of space between the block
and that way me changing the Sprite
isn't going to affect if I collide with
the object or not because remember the
Sprites kind of shift to the left or to
the right a little bit so just by adding
this multiplied by two it should make it
so that I'm never going to be colliding
left or right it will make us lose a bit
of space see how there's a bit of space
between the block now but that's okay
because now I'm never going to have that
Collision bug
um where it's going to spawn me to the
top
and really you could probably just add
one or two pixels but you can see that
that kind of fixed it right there
okay so now we have collision with
blocks we have a scrolling background we
have double jumping
I think that the last thing that we need
to add here is the fire thing right kind
of that trap where you hit it and you
kind of Flash and then once we've done
that will pretty much be done the
tutorial
all right so let's write our class for
representing our fire
so I'm going to say class fire this is
going to inherit from object as well and
this is going to be animated right we're
going to have animated fire so this will
take a bit more work but I think it'll
be worth it it looks pretty cool on the
screen
so I'm going to take X Y width and
height
and then I'm going to call my super
initializer so super
dot underscore squared knit self x y
with
and height okay and then for the name of
this I'm actually going to call it fire
remember that we can pass a name the
reason I'm adding a name to the object
is so that I can determine when I
collide with the object if it's fire and
if it's fire then I want to do something
right
okay so for self.fire I'm going to use
our load Sprite sheets function for
directory one this is going to be traps
and for directory two this is going to
be fire
now if we go here to trops you can see
that fire is one of our traps so we have
hit off on okay now there's also a bunch
of other traps right so you can you can
pick a different trap if you want like
you could pass this blink one or
whatever the thing with these ones is
that they have uh some more animations
so there's a bit more logic you need to
handle for them so that's why I'm going
with fire because it's a pretty simple
one to do
now up here for fire I'm again gonna
have my animation delay so let's make
that equal three
and now let's specify our image so let's
say our self.image is going to be
self.fire
off we're going to start with it off
and then zero okay then I'm going to say
self.mask is equal to pygame dot mask
Dot from surface self Dot
image like that
okay then I need to set an animation
count so I'm going to say my animation
underscore count is equal to zero just
like we did for our player and I need to
set myself dot animation underscore name
which for now is going to be equal to
off
okay now I'm going to make a few
functions my first function is going to
be on or my first method and I'm going
to say self dot animation name is equal
to on if we look at fire we see we have
hit off on we're not going to use hit
we're just going to use off and on
okay now we're going to have off
self.animation name
is equal to off okay and then we'll have
our Loop we'll say Define Loop self and
inside of our loop we're going to do a
very similar thing to what we did inside
of our player Loop in fact so similar
that I can copy pretty much all of this
right here so let's copy all that
and let's paste that here now for update
rather than actually just calling an
update method we'll just copy
the stuff from the update method here
and just paste it down
okay and rather than self.sprite we're
going to change this to image and I
actually think that once we remove the
direction here this is all that we need
for our um
all right so now we just need to make a
few changes we're going to get rid of
this Sprite sheet name and rather than
Sprite sheet name we're going to say
self
dot animation name
and now we should actually be good to
just use this so let me space this out a
bit we get our Sprites okay this isn't
going to be self that Sprites no it's
not gonna be self-destrates it's gonna
be self.fire which is this okay really I
probably should call this something else
but
fire is going to represent all of our
fire images okay so I'm using this to
get my different animations
I'm getting the animation name that I'm
currently playing so either on or off
and then I'm saying my Sprite index is
equal to self.animation count
divided by the self.animation delay mod
the line of Sprites same as what we had
before my image is equal to Sprites at
Sprite index and then I increment the
animation count update my rectangle and
update my mask which is important for
the collision and I'm good now last
thing I want to do here
is I want to just check if my
self.animation count is greater than
actually if this divided by myself dot
animation delay is greater than the line
of Sprites
now the reason I want to do this is so
that my animation count doesn't get too
large now you'll notice in my player
class I actually didn't do this now that
was intentional because if you do this
then it kind of messes up how the double
jump works you can do it if you want but
you'll see that it kind of messes with
things and with our player we're
constantly resetting the animation
account when we jump or when we go left
or when we go right so that value
doesn't really get too large but here
for our fire since it's just static like
it's just sitting forever what will
happen is the animation count if we
never change it back to zero we'll get
to an extremely large number which can
kind of lag our program so what I want
to do is just make it smaller right so
if it goes beyond what the actual
animation
um what do you call this is the line of
the Sprites are then I want to set this
to zero it's important I divide it by
the animation delay though because if
I'm dividing it here I need to divide it
here before I set it back to zero okay
so now we have fire and that's actually
all we need for fire so now we just need
to add it to our objects so let's create
it let's say
fire it's equal to Fire and what do we
need to pass for fire we need an X Y
width and height so we can pick where we
want to put this
um where do I want to put my X and Y
okay for now let's go 100 and let's go
height minus the block size and then I
don't know how tall my fire is going to
be I've got to see how big I want to
make this let's make it say 64.
and then we'll go 32 64 here
okay so if we look at fire
let's quickly have a look here and go to
off for example or on
the size of this is 32 by 64. okay
that's what the size is and you need to
pass that correctly to the fire class
otherwise it won't load the image
properly
so we take our height minus our block
size minus 64 which will put us on top
of a block
now I will put this at yeah 100 is fine
for now for the X and yeah 32 with 64
height there we go we have our fire
now I'm just going to say fire.on I'm
just going to turn it on we'll just
leave it on forever you can turn off
programmatically if you want and then
inside of objects I'll just place my
fire
now that I've done that it should just
show up on the screen when I run my code
so I got an issue let's see what the bug
is here of course the output is not
showing up correctly it says and it
takes
from five to six positional arguments
which seven were given
uh okay
I see the issue here
let's go back to our fire and we don't
want to pass self
let's remove self okay let's run this
uh list index out of range self.fire off
zero
okay I'm wondering why that's giving us
an issue we have off here so that should
have been okay so let's go here and
let's print self.fire and let's see why
it's giving us this uh this bug here all
right so I've determined the issue and
the issue is that I passed the incorrect
size here it's actually 16 by 32. so I
was passing too large of a size and
that's why it wasn't giving us the
correct number of images
so let's change this now and run and now
we should be okay and there we go now we
have fire uh but however it is off now
the reason it's off is because we didn't
call the loop method on fire so let's
fix that
and also get rid of the print statement
uh that I put here that I don't need
anymore
okay so let's go down to Main and where
we have player.loop let's call fire.loop
and is asking for the FPS
I don't know if I took that in my Loop
here
no I don't need the FPS for that so
let's get rid of that
okay now let's call it and it should
start being on
uh fire object has not actually Sprite
okay let's go fix that error my
apologies
fire we have Sprite somewhere here that
we don't want self.spray this is gonna
be self thought
image and self Dot
image all right start with that let's
run it now
and there we go we now have a moving
fire and notice that
I can kind of be on top of the fire
right so I can collide with it and it's
like Pixel Perfect Collision pretty much
when I'm hitting it
so now the last thing we need is to just
make it so we go into that kind of hit
State when we do hit the fire that's
actually pretty easy to do we just need
to add a kind of state to our player to
know if we're hit or not so we're going
to say self.hit is equal to false
we also want to hit count
because we're gonna only be flashing for
a certain amount of time
then we're going to have a method here
to find
hit
self
.hit equals true
and self.hit count
is equal to zero then we're going to go
in Loop and before our update Sprite
we're going to say if
self dot hit
then self dot hit count
plus equals one and then we're going to
say if self dot hit count is greater
than and we can just pick some value but
let's say FPS multiplied by two which is
going to be two seconds then the self
dot hit is equal to false
then we go here into our update Sprite
and we say
actually at the top here if self dot hit
it's important you put this at the top
by the way so make sure you put it here
then we are going to say the Sprite
sheet is equal to
hit
great
then we want to now determine if we
actually got hit so we do that from our
Collision functions which are going to
be here
all right so we have Collide left we
have Collide right and we're going to
have
vertical
collide
now what we're going to do is we're
essentially going to Loop through all of
these objects and we're going to see if
we hit fire now the way we'll know if we
hit fire is by looking at all the
objects that were returned here and it
will tell us well if if we hit fire or
not right it's because we can look at
the name of the object and if the name
of the object is fire then we know we
hit fire so I'm going to say
to check is equal to collide left
Collide right and asterisk vertical
Collide now I realize that inside of
here I only returned one object whereas
inside of here I returned all the
objects I was colliding with vertically
really we should probably be returning
all of them from here as well but I
think this is still going to work so
we'll just leave it how it is for right
now so I'm going to say for obj into
underscore check these are all the
objects we collided with remember I'm
going to say if to underscore check
and to underscore check Dot name
is equal to fire then player.hit
is able to trick
okay
that is all we need actually I'm going
to say player.hits I want to call the
method I don't want to set it equal to
true so what we're doing here is looking
through all the objects we collide with
if any of them are fire then we will put
hit on the player the reason I'm doing
this first if to check is because these
could be none right we could have no
objects we collided with so I need to
make sure I handle that case before I
try to access name on an object that
isn't defined
all right let's run the code and let's
see
and player has no object no attribute
hit count okay so let's go to player
and let's go to hit count
and let's make that equal to zero I
guess I forgot to assign that all right
let's try this now uh list object has no
attribute name okay
interesting
uh let's see here
okay all right so I'm using to check
when I need to be checking obj
so let's fix that and run the code
uh Bool object is not callable okay
player.hits aha so let's call this make
hit it's because I have an attribute
with the same name as my method so it's
accessing the attribute when it should
be accessing the method so I'm just
going to say make underscore hit and now
that should fix the problem for us
run the code and there we go now it
looks like I'm always being hit right
now
that of course is a bug
so hit is equal to false
let's check our hit count it's because
if self dot hits I'll have to hit count
plus equals one if self de hit count is
greater than self.he equals false
maybe we need to reset our hit count as
well
okay and there's probably a bug
here let's scroll down
keep scrolling
with our fire so we have to check if obj
obj and a name equals equals fire
player.make hit
okay
I'm not sure what the bug is let me run
this again
and yeah it seems like we start out in
the hit state so maybe it's an issue in
here
let's have a look here if self dot hit
Sprite sheet equals hit but we are we
hit right away for some reason it's
making us hit immediately okay let me
have a look here guys and I'll be right
back all right so I've realized I made a
silly mistake here I accidentally had
this collided objects append outside of
this if statement that was causing all
kinds of bugs and issues for me I think
I was doing some print debugging so let
me get rid of that here uh anyways I
just moved it back now so that it's in
the correct location so now if I rerun
this
now we should see that
when I hit the fire it puts me into kind
of this hit State last two seconds and
then it ends
all right so with that said guys I think
that's pretty much gonna wrap up this
video
this showed you how to create a
platformer how to do animations how to
do Sprites how to do a scrolling
background obviously there's a ton of
stuff that could be added to this game
but I really want to leave that to you
obviously I could spend hours days
months working on a game like this but I
think this is a solid enough base to
really give you guys a good foundation
to go out there and create something
pretty cool obviously there's all kinds
of assets that I will leave in the
GitHub that you can use I have all kinds
of other Pi games tutorials that you may
want to reference if you want to learn
about menus sound effects
um points scoring all of that kind of
stuff you guys just go on my channel
search Pi game tutorial you will see a
bunch of them those will show you how to
do a ton of other things that you know
you may want to add to this game so I
hope you guys enjoyed this this was a
ton of work as always the code will be
in the description if you did enjoy make
sure you leave a like subscribe to the
channel consider supporting me by
purchasing something like programming
expert and I hope to see you in another
YouTube video yo